ha sido un símbolo de la resistencia de
ucrania ahora la planta de acero de asof
tal parece estar bajo control ruso moscú
afirma haber capturado la ciudad
portuaria de mariupol tras la rendición
del último grupo de 531 combatientes de
la acería que ha sido escenario de
feroces combates y bombardeos durante
varias semanas
las construcciones subterráneas de la
planta donde se escondía el militante
han pasado a estar bajo el control total
de las fuerzas armadas rusas el
presidente ucraniano volodymyr selenski
dijo que se había ordenado al regimiento
a soft que depusieran las armas no hace
un
hoy los muchachos han recibido una señal
clara de mando militar de que pueden
salir y salvar sus vidas
los soldados ucranianos que se habían
rendido anteriormente ya llegaron a la
región de donets como prisioneros de
guerra casi 2500 se han entregado a las
fuerzas rusas en los separatistas pro
rusos desde el 16 de mayo según moscú
bosco para gobernador gildo como
logramos evacuar a los civiles y los
heridos recibieron el tratamiento médico
necesario en cuanto a los serios caídos
el proceso está en curso espero que los
familiares y toda ucrania puedan
entrenarlos con honor en un futuro
próximo y su modesto sistema ojo bate su
sueño el régimen está soft fue formado
como milicia por nacionalistas radicales
para luchar contra los separatistas
apoyados por rusia y posteriormente pasó
a formar parte de la guardia nacional
ucraniana ucrania ha expresado su
esperanza del intercambio de prisioneros
con los combatientes rendidos pero las
autoridades rusas han amenazado con
juzgar a algunos ellos por crímenes de
guerra